Do you love your dog? I mean, really. Love.
Your. Dog. … like it’s your child. ?
Hi guys, Crystal here for DNews
I live in LA and let me tell you, people there
really love their dogs. There are doggy gyms
where your dog can meet with his trainer,
doggy spas where he can get a massage, restaurants
that offer “locally sourced organic” dog
food, and places where you and your dog can
get a side-by-side mani-pedi. I know many
dog owners who say that their dog *is* their
child. Well, researchers from Massachusetts
General Hospital say that actually might not
be as crazy as it sounds …
When examining functional MRI data of women
who were shown pictures of their dogs, pictures
of their children, or neutral pictures of
unrelated dogs or children, researchers noticed
that neural activation was similar if the
subject was looking at either her own dog,
or her own child. This implies a similar level
of attachment to both the dog and the child,
and could explain why we really do treat dogs
like part of our families … we think they
are! >>In fact, in this study there were no
brain regions active when subjects viewed
photos of their own dog that were not also
activated by pictures of their own child.
But before you go out and start a savings
account for your dog’s college education,
there was a very important difference between
a mother’s response to her child, and response
to her dog. Areas of the midbrain associated
with the dopamine reward circuit were only
activated when a mother was looking at pictures
of her own child.
These crucial brain areas, the substantia
nigra and ventral tegmental area, are swimming
in receptors for all the feel good molecules
associated with the feeling of being “in
love”: dopamine, oxytocin, and vasopressin.
Activation of this midbrain region is usually
associated with human pair-bonding, basically
love and romantic relationships, and dogs,
just can’t turn it on.
So you love your dog, but you’re not “in
love” with them. and as a person not unfamiliar
with unrequited love, I thought Id ask: How
does your DOG feel about all this?
Turns out, our dogs don’t necessarily reciprocate
our feelings. In an article published in Applied
Animal Behavior Science, and titled “I like
my dog, does my dog like me?” scientists
used the Monash Dog Owner Relationship Scale
(yep thats a thing) to determine that owners
who interact more frequently with their dog,
have dogs showing more affectionate, proximity-seeking
behaviour and this might be due to more positive
reinforcement of close interaction by the
owner. Not any emotional attachment on the
part of the dog.
The study concludes “there is no support
from this study for the view that the strength
of the relationship an owner feels to his/her
dog is mirrored in the strength of the bond
of the dog to its owner”. In other words,
you can’t force your dog to love you back.
But a day at a doggy spa probably wouldn’t
hurt.
What do you think? Does your dog really love
you? Subscribe to DNews and let us know in
the comments down below! You can also come
find me on twitter at Poly Crystal H D